cannes has slapped their own sanctions
on russia banning official russian
buyers sellers and distributors from
attending the festival and refusing to
screen any films by russian directors
who support putin or had help from state
funds
we should try to discern between the
russians who are taking risk to raise
the official line and denouncing what is
happening but obviously the position of
the festival is to show absolute and
non-negotiable support to the ukrainian
people
[Music]
a russian director with a long history
with the film festival twice he was
prevented from attending his film
premieres here spending several months
under house arrest in moscow for
criticizing the kremlin he now lives in
berlin and has been vocal about his
opposition to the war though the
ukrainian film academy are calling for
an international boycott of russian
cinema he disagrees
all russian culture is unbearable
russian culture has always promoted
human values the fragility of mankind
and compassion towards those less
fortunate russian culture has always
been anti-war because war wants to
destroy the values i respect
his film tchaikovsky's wife is competing
for the palmdale prize but has been
criticized for receiving funding from
sanctioned oligarch roman abramovich
the festival has also banned russian
journalists from attending including
film critic catharina kaslidi
editor-in-chief of an independent movie
review website she left russia in
february and has no plans to return
using her personal social media
platforms to condemn the war she was
surprised to be disinvited to cannes
they didn't find any
uh
articles covering the situation in
ukraine
but uh i know i i don't know if ken
knows the way dictatorship works but
that i can't use like film rule to
do these things
um because like my staff will be
like
in danger
it's not just the festival banning some
russian related projects some film
companies have pulled titles starring
russian actors actors who've clearly
spoken out against the war the question
is if culture is about building bridges
should all of them be burnt charlie
angela al jazeera can